inside princes secret midnight movie nights the legendary musician died on Thursday and while he was known as an international superstar he really just enjoyed doing everyday things like going to the movies a source from Prince's home town of Chanhassen Minnesota tells et exclusively he'd often rent out a local theater late at night so he and his friends could watch films without causing a scene the source who called Prince a quote really normal guy said he kept a very low profile showing up in disguise to make sure he wasn't recognizable we're told he enjoyed family-friendly flicks the source added he only saw movies rated pg-13 and below and most recently saw Zootopia back in March as for snacks he'd buy water popcorn or peanut M&Ms and it seems Prince had a bit of a sweet tooth another source revealed he'd often visit upscale market lungs and Byerly's also at late night hours in disguise because he quote loved the sandwiches from there